introduce ramen hasani
so ramen finished his
bachelor in uh japan and he got to
poly me technically milano uh
as on on an award
of exceptional student i was fortunate
to
be able to recruit him afterwards uh
because he was working on
neural networks actually he was
implementing the hardware
in milano and so i
was able to to recruit him in my group
where he did an outstanding job and now
he is a postdoc at mit in the group of
daniel arras and i'm sure he's
continuing
his great activity over there so rameen
the floor is yours
thank you so much radu um all right hi
everyone
i'm going to um i'm going to describe
today
um a kind of technology we have been
working on
with radu and daniela for a couple of
years now
and this is a class of continuous time
neural networks called
liquid time constant networks so
let's get started by knowing by defining
what is a time continuous neural network
so um in time continuous neural network
determined by a flow of hidden states
x and its flow
is identified by a neural network f
number of
which is given by a number of layers n
and then
the width k and a type of activation
function
and then it's a function of its hidden
states that means it can have
feedbacks it has it's a function of its
input
and it has model parameters that so with
this kind of
terminology it can give rise to
dynamical systems
functions that we previously wouldn't be
able to
produce with normal normal neural
networks
so it was recently shown that um
they can be equivalent they can be the
continuous
depth equivalent of a residual network
that
um basically in a residual network or a
typical neural network we have um a
finite transformation
of computation graph which is
equidistant
basically as at each layer we are
computing
basically an output for for a neural
network
but then when you use a time continuous
neural network
you can have adaptive computation and
you can transform the space into a
vector field
where you can actually have a very
efficient computation
at arbitrary point based on the type of
numerical ode solver that you use
so to elaborate a little bit more about
the features of time continuous networks
let's define
let's see how a standard recurrent
neural network
discretized like a discretized version
of a continuous flow
which is um which was developed in the
90s and then
so this is actually the transformation
that you can have
computing your next value given a neural
network
that has recurrent connections inputs
it's a function of time
or inputs input sequences and it's
parameterized by parameter teta
so this is actually the transformation
of an recurrent network
and then a neural ode or a time
continuous network
the representation becomes a
differential equation
and then a more stable version of this
is called a ctrn and a ctrn is basically
just the same differential equation with
a damping factor
tau that give rise to a more stable
neural network now if i just want to
show you like how
different they are in modeling time
series
i can show you like the top part which
is a discretized recarnal network
the power of prediction and
extrapolation of um
of a typical standard uh recurring
network
is actually looks like this and the
transformer
this transformation is much more smooth
when we are using
a continuous time recurrent network and
that's one of the benefits that we can
get out of these systems so um
how do we implement these time
continuous neural networks
given a neural network by this
differential equation
then we can you can take advantage of
numerical ode solvers
so we can write their equation we can
approximate them
their next value by for example an
explicit euler
kind of discretization and then we can
get the next value
based on based on this differential
equation given here
by defining this delta t now
this is called a forward pass the
forward pass computes for you the next
value
given the current state and the current
inputs to the system
so the forward pass can be identified by
any type of uh numerical integrator or
numerical ode solver
so this numerical choice of the ode
solvers actually
identifies the forward pass complexity
now how do we train them
so you can use a method that is called
adjoint
sensitivity method again um
every time we want to train a neural
network what we want to do we want to
define a loss function
that let's define our neural ode by this
function
and the flow of neural body e in time
is given by this figure over here
at every given point in time we are
being able to compute a loss
and then this loss can be computed by a
kind of a call to an ode solver
that receives your first input and
receive
that does have the neural network f and
then it wants to arrive at a final
point and then basically you want to sum
up all those losses that you compute
based on the loss function given loss
function to compute the loss value
so our joint sensitivity method wants to
take at every single point
run an axillary differential equation
this adjoint state
that is corresponding to the derivative
of the loss
in respect to the state of the neural
network
that means at every given point if we
run this differential equation
this would be a backward run to the same
ode solver
to basically compute the previous value
of the loss
so that you can you can compute their uh
the gradients
in respect to the loss with one step
and then at the like at the current step
you can do one more
gradient propagation and you would not
require to propagate back
throughout the whole sequence this will
give you
a complexity of one basically it's a
constant complexity
when you use a joint sensitivity method
then there is another method to compute
this is called back propagation through
time it's a classical method
where we have a forward pass and then
given a forward pass what you want to
compute you want to just
go through the ode solver like how we
are um
like uh discretizing this ode and then
um computing the the loss gradients
one by one and then using the chain rule
to compute your
uh gradients and then you can update
your old parameters by new parameters
so i showed you how to do forward pass
and how to do
uh backward pass which type of of these
trainings to use depending on the
situations
because the the black propagation
through time itself comes with a comp
a really really significant computation
but it has its own advantages
so the advantage of using um back
propagation through time
comes with an error that is caused by
the adjunct sensitivity method
imagine if i show you a continuous
vector field like that
and if i give you an initial value for a
system then you can run this system
then this is actually the the actual
forward run of the system
now for the adjoint time where we want
to
make the reverse transformation the
ideal transformation was to actually go
back
directly over this trajectory but
actually the adjoint
or the e-solver can can give rise
to numerical errors for the latent error
so and
in general just want you to show that
the memory it is true that we gain
memory complexity but um
um but we actually lose backward
accuracy
so i mean in cases where compute doesn't
matter
then you can actually stay with vanilla
back propagation through time
which is a better one now um
neural odes and defining
defining neural networks in terms of
differential equations
have a lot of advantages and in
principle in in theory
um they should be extremely good for um
kind of tasks that that deal with
sequential data
and continuous time spaces such as robot
control
uh um a variety of robot control tasks
that i'm showing here so
can a neuron but but so far we haven't
seen
in the literature that abnormal neural
ode
in the form of a recurrent network can
actually be
as expressive as advanced rnns in real
world applications
so there has to be a more expressive
way to show neural odes because with
this current form
they cannot beat the state-of-the-art
classical
recarnal networks so
with this motivation we decided to look
at the problem differently
so we gave rise to a category
of neural networks that their hidden
states
are actually computed by a very simple
linear ode
and this linear ode has a damping factor
or a
time constant tau is which is a constant
value
and receives a specialized input s
this specialized input s now is
identified by a neural network
multiplied by the difference of a
parameter
of a biasing parameter minus the state
of the neural network
so with this definition if i add
this s inside the equation one
what i can get i can get a more complex
representation of a
of an ode that has
a special characteristics for example
as we see here the coefficient of
x of t in this equation was only tau a
constant value
so and this coefficient actually defines
the characteristics of the differential
equation
given no input autonomous behavior of
the system
now the coefficient of x is defined by
the neural network itself
so that means at every given time point
in time we would have a different
dynamical system that is adaptable to
the environment so
defining the diff uh basically the
the state of the neural network would be
solution of this initial value problem
and then which has a variable time
constant
the neural network f also appears in the
state in defining the state
of the differential equation and also
inside
the time constant element or the
coefficient of x element
which is different and we recently
showed that this system actually comes
with
a lot of attractive behavior for example
if i
call this coefficient a time constant of
the system
and also defining the whole state of the
neural network x of t
we showed that even if the inputs to
this system goes to infinity that
the time constant of the system this
time constant of the system
for every nodes inside the neural
network
is actually stable and is bounded
between two
um like lower bound and after that
we also showed that uh the state itself
for every neuron or every node inside
these
liquid time constant networks or ltc's
they are they're also bounded so that's
also another nice
uh property of these um networks
another uh property of this network is
that like
i arbitrarily choose uh um
um chose um a kind of differential
equation
for myself and then is it a universal
approximate or not
can we approximate any kind of dynamics
by
uh by an arbitrary precision with these
networks
then we also follow um the kind of
principles of universal approximation
for neural networks
to actually show that this system also
has universal approximation capabilities
but then um where how
deep and how these neural networks
are basically more expressive like
universal approximation applies to all
types of neural networks
how can we distinct between like shallow
networks
and deep networks so for actually
digging a little bit deeper into the
foundation of
how expressive are these liquid time
constant networks
we use one of the nice definitions that
uh the deep learning community
actually came up with it's called the
extra it's called the trajectory lengths
um measure of expressivity imagine you
have a trajectory a 2d trajectory
circle and you want to input this
trajectory
inside a neural network a normal neural
network
and then what you have you have a neural
network with n layers
and with k and it's and its weights are
actually sampled from this end
then the observation was that if you
project
the trajectory input trajectory to this
system
layer by layer in this neural network we
see that the complexity of these
trajectories increases by the number of
layers
not only the complexity of this
increases
but also if we compute the lengths or
arc lengths of this trajectory
this arc length has a lower bound that
is exponential in the number of layers
that means
the the lengths here is your neural
network the more the
the the the deeper is your neural
network the more
expressive you might get based on these
trajectory lines
so that's a measure of expressivity that
sets the boundary between
shallow networks and deep networks so we
try to formulate the same thing
and apply this to a couple of
continuous time recurrent neural network
kind of
algorithms neural ode architectures
and ltc's and then we project back the
activity
into 2d for this uh
basically continuous time neural
networks and we observed that
continually
we saw that the trajectory lengths in 2d
for the ltc models are basically longer
and more complex
for example here we show that if you're
just changing the
weighting initialization of the of the
neural network
you can create extremely complex
patterns
by ltcnet networks while
the complexity and the lengths of the
trajectory
of the neural ode and
and ctrns are basically stays very very
uniformly
and then we also like try to
extend this to to actually see that by
changing the many variables
uh inside these architectures can be
actually keep
our uh interpretation of this system so
can can we can we actually prove that
these systems are more uh expressive in
terms of
um trajectory lengths and that's
actually the case so the yellow line
here in all curves
where we are showing into different ode
solvers different network
with then we have um initialization
weighting initialization
scale and also network layers
then um we also um
approved like some lower bounds for we
found some lower bounds for the
trajectory lengths
or the expressivity of neural odes
uh ctrns and ltc representations
and then based on that we actually
validated that our theory actually
works uh our and also our experimental
results are kind of validated so if
these systems are more expressive
in in theory then what would uh how
would they
uh compare against the state of the art
um
in in real world applications for
example if you look at the
like movement of cheetah we can see that
if you want to model that behavior then
um
ltcs outperform lscm policies
continuous time gre units and
neural odes as well if we
compare them in a real world application
of person recognition
uh like per person pattern like this is
this is a data set where
um it's like a time series of activity
of a human body and you want to classify
sequence of behavior
into certain pattern we see that ltcs
are also
kind of performant we also took
a couple of real world applications and
then we saw that in most cases
ltcs are outperforming other models
and now what i want to show in summary
so far
to you is that we introduced this model
we showed that it's universal
approximator
we showed that it has a stable dynamics
and also they show better degrees of
accuracy
expressivity and they can vary their
behavior
even post training because of the
liquidity
and um so um these systems are also good
for
irregularly sampled data one of the one
of the
um examples i showed you like
the tables we benchmark against this
irregularly
sampled data and they can actually model
continuous time processes pretty
effectively
but now can we scale the applications of
ltc
into even larger networks like because
the examples i showed you like
these are all small examples and
something with larger impact and maybe
even exploit
what is actually possible to do with
this type of modeling system
for example how can we apply this system
to um to um
end-to-end control of cars like
autonomous driving
where uh we collect a bunch of human
data and then we want to perform
at the driving activity so
in the current autonomous vehicles that
are camera based
for example tesla autopilot we have
some sort of like the inputs are rgb
images
they actually go through a kind of
cascade of layers of convolutional
networks
followed by fully connected layers that
actually
shape off shape up the whole thing as
like 20 to 100 million
parameters or let's say like you can
even scale it down from 5 million to
let's say 100 million parameters this
system can
actually drive a car end-to-end
then um what we actually try to ask
is that what happens if we can actually
replace the
fully connected layers where we have an
overload of parameters training
parameters
with recurrent neural networks and what
happens if we use ltc
based networks and then compare the
performance
of four different architectures where we
have lstms
as a control unit right after
convolutional layers
we have ctrns or neural odes basically
right after the convolutional layers the
convolutional neural network
and an architecture we call this just
based on a
network of ltc systems is a four-layer
specific architecture which we call
neural circuit policies which is built
by the ltc model
and we want to see what can be gained if
we actually
formulate this it turns out that to do
it
to do the autonomous driving in real
world
which we would need only 19 neurons of
ncp neurons
with as much smaller convolution on our
network
and much smaller number of trainable
parameters
that's one of the advantages of having
an expressive model
inside a larger scale problem
and other aspects of these networks is
um i would like to
talk over it like with this video so um
this is now a normal
um convolutional neural network with
fully connected layers
and it's fully connected layers are
showing here negativity of the fully
connected layers
while the driving is happening because
this is the input to the neural network
and neural network has to do
this decide about how to actually go
about the driving
we see that a convolutional neural
network this is actually what
is out there right now similar to this
architecture
is over the tesla autopilot so
what we have here on the on the
bottom here what i'm what i'm showing is
the attention
map of the convolutional layers
while the driving is happening in this
street
so we see that the convolutional neural
network is attending to this
roads sideways to to make a driving
decision
mostly that's the case when driving
happens if i add a little bit of noise
over this what we see
is that the attention map or the
decision of the networks
are not reliable anymore and that's one
of the fundamental problems it is true
that a convolutional network can
actually solve this problem
but also their decisions are not going
to be reliable anymore
instead of that if we actually use
um an ncp network which only has 19
neurons
basically what you get is an attention
on the roads horizon so basically it's
kind of capturing the main
causality of the data and also
even if i add noise on my data
look at the attention map it is
definitely
affected by the noise but what we see
is that its concentration is mostly
preserved so its decisions are more
robust compared to other networks
here what i'm showing you is a time
sequence of
inputs to a neural network with
lstm networks this is the attention map
of an lstm network
attention map of neural odes
convolutional networks and ncps
we see that there is actually a
consistently
focus on the horizon while we are using
an ncp network
and that's one of the very nice features
of these um
networks that we actually um explored
and found
um empirically
another thing that we found is that um
the number of
crash like imagine i on the x-axis i'm
increasing the amount of noise
and the y-axis i'm measuring the number
of crashes
that would happen in real world then we
see that ncb's
the ones that is on the lower side is
actually
much more resilient to perturbations
another recent work that we were
actually
looking at was in
what is the underlying principle like
can we actually mathematically talk
about
is there really like this liquid time
constant network ltc networks are they
really causal models
that's actually another work that is on
the revision right now where we actually
show
um um theoretically that
a system composed of let's say a
dynamical causal model
be two neurons let's say we have two
neurons and they they're connected
through these synopsis together
dynamical causal models
would uh allow inter intervention
for from outside world onto the synaptic
parameters
of two neurons that are interacting with
each other they have an internal
coupling
and they have basically a fixed
parameter that affect that
controls or tunes the inputs directly to
this
uh x i or the neural number two and then
if you have an
analogy of to the liquid time constant
networks
we see that we would have the same
type of constants but here we have a
kind of non-linearity
we have a non-linear control that is
controlled by neural network so a neural
network actually
controls how the interaction between two
neurons
are basically formed
and this is actually where the liquidity
modulator or a non-linear liquidity
modulator is actually coming up
and this this is what we found in the
paper then what we showed we showed it
on
[Music]
a task of drone navigation so what
you're seeing is that
this there is a drone that is learned
only by visual inputs to actually move
towards the target
so we see that on the right hand side
what we see is that
as soon as the drone realizes that there
is a target
all the attention of the ncp network is
actually comes on the
um on the target and that's actually
something that
came without even coding this and
without any inductive bias inside the
system
we also tested it on multi-agent system
so what i'm showing here
is a view from a first drone or a
follower drone
and the drone inside the environment is
actually a
leader drone and then
the the follower drone actually learned
how to attend to this um second run
while performing a task of leader
following
and now in the leader following task if
you look into the attention of the
network
like this is the view from the first
drone to the second drone which is here
we see that the attention of the network
is actually on
um on the first drone
and this is actually one of the uh
really cool observations that we could
connect
ltc networks as causal models
so they are actually causal models as
well
i would like to thank you for your
attention with this
and um would like to invite you i also
like to thank
my collaborators radhu daniela alexander
and matthias
and um so that we have we have open
sourced
all our uh kind of technologies you can
actually get access in both
uh tensorflow and python if you want to
get hands-on
and um with that uh thank you for your
attention
thank you i mean this was super exciting
uh i'd like to open the floor to
questions
the chat will work or a microphone will
work
so i have a question uh mr randall so
so why do you think these networks uh
are more expressive than let's say
classical neuralgi's
yeah so one of the things is that we use
this measure you know like we use the
expressivity measure
which was the um you know like the the
trajectory lengths
their trajectory length is actually one
of the nice measures in deep learning
community
where it actually unifies for example
one of the measures of expressivity in
deep
neural networks is number of linear
regions
that as a result of like adding neural
networks
you would have you would have a space
let's say you have a 2d space like a
like a really abstract 2d space so the
more relu networks
you add the more number of regions you
create
inside this space so basically it
measures the number of complexity but
then
trajectory length is is a better measure
for expressivity and it was shown in
in a paper in 2017 that is actually a
good
way to to to measure expressivity of a
network so we theoretically figured out
that these networks are more expensive
and by how much i mean
well i mean i showed um
in some cases it is exponentially better
depending on what your
so this is actually the trend so let's
say let's say if i
increase the increase the size of a
neural network
then the yellow line here is basically
the
first of the an order of magnitude the
the length of the trajectory is higher
and at the same time the trends are kind
of similar
okay like the trend how the complexity
can increase
okay and then there is also an
exponential increase in the
how how how you're uh initializing your
weight values
imagine you your rate values of your
neural network of
are of these orders and then you have an
exponential increase in all but the
overall ltcs are better than the others
thanks
thank you i would love to ask a few
questions but in the interest of time
thank you rameen for the great talk and
we'll move to the next speaker
mayor nike is here even mayor